i'll give you a great example of
censorship a true this is orwellian i
know that word gets overused but this is
orwellian
right now if you go to yelp.com what do
you use it for
you're in a new area you say i want uh i
don't know i want chinese food time
let's look up chinese food then you look
on yelp and you have different reviews
and you can see which
has the best chinese food
now there's a new feature on yelp which
is you'll see you know sometimes it'll
say four stars it'll maybe say three
dollar signs
how expensive it is now you can see a
little exclamation point in red
that is to let you know that the
business has been accused of
racist behavior
racist behavior what what
does that mean what you will see is a
little pop-up and it says recently
someone associated with this business
was accused of racist
behavior resulting in an influx of
people posting views to this page
racism is reprehensible and has no place
on yelp and we unequivocally reject
racism in any form wow how brave
unlike all those people who totally
support racism right you know racism
that
that pervasive thing that's totally real
not just
a boogeyman and a straw man that the
left uses
that the demagogues on the left use to
shut down anybody who disagrees with
them
like that whole thing do you condemn
white supremacy who supports
who embraces white supremacy do you know
anybody who says yeah i love white
supremacy
i'm a huge white supremacist no
it's a phantom issue when people say
black lives matter i'm
bravely courageously saying black lives
matter how many people do you know say
yeah black lives man they don't matter i
hate those lives
none no nobody everybody thinks black
lives matter nobody
disagrees with the statement black lives
matter but a lot of people
believe that a lot of other people who
are not as virtuous and wonderful as
themselves
that a lot of other nefarious people
they they all say black lives don't
matter same thing with racism
nobody in this country maybe a handful
of people
would call themselves racists
but they think a whole lot of other
people are racist while we understand
the desire to warn others about racist
behavior about a business all reviews on
yelp must reflect an actual first-hand
customer experience so we've
temporarily disabled the ability to post
here as we work to investigate the
content
if you you're here to leave a review
based on a first-hand experience please
check back at a later date so
what they're saying here is they're
trying to i guess
be helpful uh if we're to give them the
benefit of the debt it's to be helpful
right because they're saying
basically there's some incident at a
place and they say it's racism
often by the way these are hoaxes this
happened very famously
outside of oberlin university there was
a restaurant that was accused of
racism and they had to shut down it was
a total hoax
so that happens then people flood it who
don't know they say you're a racist
you're a racist whatever
so they're saying okay we're going to
stop that you're not allowed to do that
but the way they're going to stop it is
by putting a big sign that says accused
of racist behavior
define racist behavior for me i'll give
you an example
uber eats during the george floyd riots
uber eats decided that they were going
to
waive the delivery fee for black owned
businesses whatever that means
define a black owned business for me
what if a black guy owns a quarter of
the business but
is that a black owned business or do you
only get to waive a quarter of the
delivery fee whatever
so they say we're going to waive
delivery fees for black owned businesses
we're going to charge delivery fees for
white owned businesses
so you're you're penalizing people on
the basis of their race
right you're just saying we're going to
charge more money we're going to make it
harder for your business to operate if
you're
if you have one race but not if you're
of another race which is
the definition of racism so is uber eats
gonna get
a racism warning on yelp probably not
probably not what about uh businesses
who buy into the blm lie
that all white people are racist because
we live in a white supremacist
country that's a racist statement are
those people
with the big blm sign are they going to
get the no they're not
they're not it's just it's just a way of
signaling
which are the officially approved
businesses by the liberal establishment
and which are not which are verboten
you're not allowed to go there
there are there are parallels to other
tyrannical sort of political regimes
here
and you see it creeping slowly and you
kind of see how
how this kind of mad cultural madness
can take over but that is where we're
headed
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you